Steve's in Pittsburgh hey Steve welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show great cause yes
you too how can I help sir so I'm
Caroline babysit - I got one sorry my
life and everybody needs it - 5000 watts
on a student loan but um like I said you
told me there David so insult when to
leave me so I'm kind of got a pickle
here I just the next step so this is
just totally blindsided and I haven't
travelled myself together here and it's
just bluffing easy there yeah so how
long have you guys been married
haha well 17 we first started dating but
in year 15 years nerd for nine we're
going to celebrate in your ar-15
dating anniversary our 10-year wedding
anniversary this this year but helping
when they get there what's happened what
happened to the marriage you know it's
nothing to be since we got together so
young we just we both grew up together
we just kind of guard
I guess interested good it became
different it's just I want some place
I'm in shock
but from what she told me she said yeah
I guess it's one of the things that we
kind of grew apart and again I'm still
um I just I didn't feel it but she's the
one that said we did and I I don't know
what to do okay
how old are you gosh 32 I'm guessing
you're not a part of a good local church
well I actually reached this just
happened on Monday and I reached out to
my church yesterday and I I was talking
to them I tried to get over the pastor I
couldn't get ahold of him but I did
schedule some something to talk to them
earlier in the week this week here okay
that's good move yeah yeah if the two of
you can sit down a good pastoral
counseling on marriage
you know you take a shot at saving this
so I think that's what you work on right
now Steve okay you've only got $5,000 in
debt and you said right and is it yes
your student loan in your name or hers
it's in my name and there's no other dad
in the house
correct do you mortgage the owner home
yes okay and how much do you make
I make 42 okay how much does she make
she makes closer to 80 what'd she do
[Music]
okay children - yeah - kids eight and
almost six okay all right yeah I think
ninety-eight percent of your energy is
on working aggressively to see if
there's any kind of saving this
situation that's your first thing the as
far as the money parts go you don't have
a lot of debt and you know you can work
your way through that debt making 42 or
making 122 depending on what it is that
that works doable you'll end up with
your student loan if a divorce occurs
and the house will be split if a divorce
occurs typically in most situations like
this and so that means it's going to be
sold and there's going to be or whatever
equities there's going to be handed to
each of you I would not I do not
recommend in the event of a divorce in
fact I strongly recommend against it
that one of you stay in the house and
the other ones stay on the mortgage if
you're gonna cook that if either one is
going to keep the house it needs to be
refinanced and get the other morning off
the mortgage so don't you okay or
quitclaim the house to her and give her
your half and then you stay on the
mortgage don't you dare do that okay
that'll bite you later on if this comes
down to that hopefully it won't
hopefully you guys can turn this around
I'm sorry I know you're back on your
heels and you've been punched in the
face with this news and you're trying to
figure out what to do I understand but I
don't think the financial part
friend of mine that does divorce
counseling says a divorce turns a
marriage into a business transaction and
so what that means is just splitting up
the math after that yeah there's all the
emotion and the heartbreak and the hurt
and the anger and everything else that
goes with it but the math the finances
of a divorce are just a business
transaction
it's just simple you know audition
subtraction division long division
it's what amounts to sorry sorry you're
facing that